you talk to his mother yeah what was  that about did you find anything out we  sure did grey's Anatomy's star Katharina  score selfie confirms she's pregnant  the actress exclusively told ET she's  expecting her second child with husband  Rob Giles  gushing that their quote very very  excited and keeping the gender of the  baby a secret for now  Katerina revealed the good news on  Thursday at the Disney ABC TCA party in  Beverly Hills where she flaunted her  baby bump in a figure-hugging black  dress as for how her pregnancy will  impact her role as dr. Amelia Shepherd  Katarina explained quote it'll be  challenging it's going to happen  somewhere during the shooting season but  shaundalyn is the best place for that to  happen she also admitted it won't be  written into Emilia storyline joking  that she'll probably be wearing more lab  coats come fall when the drama series  returns to ABC for its thirteenth season